piaces theory argues that we have to
conquer four stages of cognitive
development first the sensorimotor stage
second the pre-operational stage third
the concrete operational stage and
fourth the formal operational stage only
once we have gone through all the stages
at what age can vary we are able to
reach full human intelligence one the
sensorimotor stage ages birth to two in
the sensorimotor stage we develop their
experiences and movement our five senses
our brain wants to see hear smell taste
and touch as much as possible first we
start with simple reflexes and soon
after we develop our first habits from
four months old we become aware of
things beyond our own body and then as
we get older we learn to do things
intentionally a key milestone is the
development of working memory or in
Piaget terms our realization of object
permanence before that our mom can show
and then hide a teddy and we would think
is gone after we understand that objects
continue to exist even when we can't see
them we start becoming curious about
everything we want to smell flowers
taste food listen to sounds and talk to
strangers to explore more we move we
learn to sit crawl stand walk and even
to run this increased physical mobility
consequently leads to increased
cognitive development but we remain
egocentric meaning we can perceive the
world only from our own point of view to
the pre-operational stage ages 2 to 7
[Music]
our thinking is mainly categorized for
symbolic functions and intuitive
thoughts we have lots of fantasies and
believe objects are alive as we are not
able to apply specific cognitive
operations
Piaget calls this stage pre-operational
we learn to speak and understand that
words images and gestures are symbols
for something else when we draw our
family we are not concerned about
drawing each person to scale but rather
with their symbolic meanings we love to
play pretend which allows us to
experience something new and learn a lot
at around age 4
most of us become very curious and ask
many questions we want to know
everything we can call it the birth of
primitive reasoning Piaget calls it the
intuitive age because while we realize
that we have a vast amount of knowledge
we have no idea how we acquired it our
thinking in this stage is still pretty
egocentric we think others see the world
like we do and still don't understand
that they see it differently 3 the
concrete operational stage ages 7 to 11
we finally discover logic and we develop
concrete cognitive operations such as
sorting objects in a certain order one
example of this is inductive reasoning
which means that if we see someone
eating a cookie we can draw a conclusion
and then make a generalization and we
now get the concept of conservation we
understand that if we pour orange juice
from a normal glass to a taller one the
amount stays the same our younger sister
will pick the taller glass thinking she
gets more by the same logic we only now
can understand that if 3 plus 5 equals 8
then 8 minus 3 must equal 5
our brain learns to rearrange our
thoughts to classify and build concrete
operational mental structures for
example we now know that we can reverse
an action by doing the opposite excited
by our new mental abilities we apply
them in conversations activities when we
learn to write and in school as a result
we get to know ourselves better we begin
to understand that our thoughts and
feelings are unique and not necessarily
those of others that means that we learn
to put ourselves in someone else's shoes
[Music]
for the formal operational stage age 12
plus once we become teenagers we become
formally operational we now have the
ability to think more rationally about
abstract concepts and hypothetical
events our advanced cognitive abilities
allow us to understand abstract concepts
such as success and failure love and
hate we form a deeper understanding of
our own identity and our morality we now
also think that we understand why people
behave the way they behave and as a
result can become more compassionate our
brain can now do deductive reasoning
which means we can compare two
statements and reach a logical
generalization our new mental skills
allow us to plan our life systematically
and prioritize and we can make
assumptions about events that have no
necessary relation to reality we can now
also philosophize and just think about
thinking itself our new sense for our
identity now also creates egocentric
thoughts and some start to see an
imaginary audience watching them all the
time
Piaget believed in lifelong learning but
insisted that the formal operational
stage is the final stage of our
cognitive development
[Music]
jean piaget 'he's first interests were
animals and he published his first
scientific paper on albino sparrows in
1907 when he was just 11 years old in
1920 he began working with standardized
intelligence tests he realized that
younger children consistently make types
of mistakes that older children do not
he concluded that they must think
differently and spent the rest of his
life studying the intellectual
development of children
[Music]
you